you don't know the extent or how it's
affecting affecting people that if
you've not been through it and and also
there'd be amount of people ice infects
them and that's when you know want to
read them numbers and started reading
into it that's that's what sort of push
mentor to try and make a difference it's
not only the food situation that I was
thinking about when I was raising
awareness it's other stuff you know
mental health and just just the
well-being of people and families and
and that's just one less thing that they
have to think of us or you know they
probably are in in more difficult
situations than worrying about only food
you know people are worrying about their
jobs and and what they're going to do
for income and stuff like that so it's
just one less thing to put in to worry
about and you know it's something that
you shouldn't have to worry about we
have to make England what we what we
want it to look that you know and I said
before I feel that everyone's got got
good intentions what things have
happened in the past we have to make me
change for it to improve in the future
and you know maybe something like this
it won't it'll have an effect on my
generation but I'm more looking at the
younger kids and what their future will
look like very proven Medicaid so you
know there's a bigger picture to it and
offer that this will sort of continue
now and it will become you'll become
normal